all right so you're doing this you do
the play you like it yeah you're done
with the band at this point
no i'm still doing this you're still
doing the band went off now you're
acting and you're starting to do
stand-up comedy
yeah so you're doing all these things
and you're having a good time but you're
not making a lot of money no no it's mo
and it's mostly banned stuff and when i
first come to la i'm working at
starbucks
and then i start taking classes at the
groundlings that's that all the music
stuff stopped
and i had a teacher melanie graham who
was in the main company at the
groundlings
amazing woman
she was like
you don't want to be working at
starbucks dude and i was like no [ __ ]
of course not but i got a bill space
she's like she was a writer on
the real world right a story editor and
she's like i can get you a job at puna
murray
it'll be like watching videotapes and
entering info and i was like yeah i'll
take it
and that's what got me into reality tv
and i would uh every now and then
through the groundlings get an audition
for like a commercial were you pretty
happy at this point were you uh yeah you
were it was a good part of your life
i met people at the groundlings that i'm
still super incredibly tight with people
who've
i've worked with now who um
are now like huge stars and like
we were just kids in our twenties who
are those people like my rudolph and i
were in oh you're close with maya yeah
maya and i were in classes i i have a
photo i'll show you of me and maya is
sitting on stage with the growlings and
we look like
15 year olds we look like babies wow and
um
yeah well forte was there when i was
there
and you went through the whole program
i did
all the classes now you do all
there's
a basic class and it's just improv
that's what i took then there's an
intermediate class which is just improv
then there's a writer's lab
which they teach you how to write
sketches in the writer's lab
at i think six to 12 weeks of doing it
you put on a show of the sketches you've
written
and then and you did that did that
great loved it mike mcdonald was my
teacher
he came from some
different i should say mike yeah michael
mcdonald he was on mad tv
he was my teacher and then mindy
sterling was my advanced teacher
and um
then for advance you do improv and
sketch comedy you write for six weeks to
a show right for six more weeks do a
show
and the groundlings main company members
have to come and watch both your shows
and then they vote like
yeah let's move them up to the sunday
company where you do shows every sunday
and okay
i did not make it into the sunday
company and i didn't crushed because you
were in with all these people they liked
you you're friends with them all you're
working hard i was working at the
theater also at this point i was working
in the box office i was videotaping
shows i was
that theater was my life for like four
years do you know who rejected you
no but let me tell you this i don't know
if this is
this is how it happened but
so they have to vote on you
the only company members that can vote
are ones that have seen both the advance
shows
the night of our second show
there was a bomb threat on melrose
avenue and we had to cancel the show
and reschedule it for the next night
most of the company members couldn't
come the next night so
i think
only like two or three people voted on
our shows
and i think there were people that were
not thrilled with the fact that i was
a student but already hanging out with
everybody backstage and like
too familiar
that's what i think and you were crushed
crushed i had no other plans i was like